this is a good segue cause my friends
why is it
that washington dc is putting up these
permanent barricades now
in the green zone you hear about this
yeah you know they said
the barricades all around dc yeah yeah
it's permanent okay when did this decide
when they decided to make this last
minute
okay and they're going to leave 5 000
national guardsmen there i've heard of
this
you know why there is a real threat
there is they keep saying there's like a
threat of white supremacy in the far
right
it's not really that i mean they'll say
that but there is a threat
the real threat is the rebel who can see
the shed
they can see now through the shattered
veil it's almost like the matrix
and then one day all these robots are
tending to the human crop and then a
bunch of humans wake up
and they can see what's going on around
them and if the machine doesn't get a
hold of things those people are going to
get real angry and they're going to rise
up
so we see this massive security effort
in dc now we see
the next and most interesting iteration
in the desperation of the state because
they're really scared about what happens
when people realize
not only is the game rigged but we are
stealing everything from you and your
family and we're laughing the whole way
down
a new gun bill would require public
registry of all weapons this is
hr127 this is
one of the most insane things i've ever
read to the point where i really don't
think it will pass
but this is a new gun control measure
it's been proposed by uh jackson lee
sheila a democrat from texas and it's
gonna it requires a lot of things i
don't know if you have a lot of the
the points on the gun control bill i do
that you want to bring up specifically i
want to bring up
more about that security theater you
were bringing up because there's a cnn
legal analyst
named elliott williams who tweeted quote
seems like a good day for a reminder
that
in any other year hundreds of giddy
children from across washington dc
would be sledding at the capitol
building all day long
they can't because the grounds are
closed to the public following a
domestic terrorist attack
and then i mean just the hyperbolic just
the fear-mongering just the nonsense
there and i think michael tracy had a
response that is worth noting here and
commenting on
and he said or alternatively the
children can't sled on the hill
because a security theater panic has
been ginned up
and virtually no one in a position of
influence has bothered even questioning
it
and i think he's wrong why it's not
security theater
it could be no no no no no i'll tell you
it's that the media right now their lies
are so obvious
luke you were telling me about the kill
dozer yes i watched
a documentary about the kill dozer and
my goodness gracious uh that was the
gist of the kill dozer story
it was an individual who felt wronged by
city council and he decided
to take out his feelings of being
mistreated by the government by
literally building
huge slabs of steel surrounding the
giant
bulldozer which he put in a 50 caliber
firearm that was shooting out of and
other rifles out of through little ports
and went on a rampage in a small
town literally going after anyone who
thought he
was wrong by him they couldn't stop him
it's called the kill dozer
and he only got stopped because his kill
dozer fell into a basement
when he was just he like destroyed a
city councilman's house or whatever
well he's going after one of the uh
businesses that was owned by one of the
people that okay okay i was wrong
it's not security theater now the media
is lying about in my opinion i think the
media is lying about the threat the far
right
now i think the real threat is that the
veil has been
shattered they know it they know we can
now
see them all working the machines behind
the scenes going uh-oh
what do we do now if you have one person
who feels wronged by the government in
that way
and this one person goes nuts and builds
a killdozer i mean this is freaky stuff
we don't want this stuff we don't want
this this this no no we need to do
everything in our power to prevent
violence
but you probably as much as we can by
having justice but these these these
crony machi
the crony machine doesn't want that
instead they're now
putting up massive barricades around the
capitol so that so they're like
we know what's coming we know the rage
is there and they don't care
if it's look the media will tell you one
thing but that's the point i bring up
that's why i bring up
this new firearms yeah restriction like
the restrictions hr127
they want you to have a license and
insurance and a whole bunch of crazy
things listen
the crazy thing about it is that there
are a lot of people right now who have a
bunch of guns they would want you to pay
pay fees
get liability insurance they would want
you to register each and every weapon
mandatory psych evaluations a national
gun owner license gun insurance for
everything
as well as a publicly accessible
database
and they want to ban 50 bmgs i mean are
are you kidding me i mean this is
absolutely draconian
this is frightening this is terrifying
because you know there's going to be a
lot of individuals who are not going to
register their firearms
and this this this you know house
resolution makes it so you have to
or you face penalties and fines that
could land you in jail for
a year to 40 years look at this let me
read you
from this article i have this is from
the daily fly they say a pro-gun group
called the citizens committee for the
right to keep and bear arms called the
bill
insanity on steroids they say over the
years we've seen some astonishingly bad
legislation originated on capitol hill
but this one takes the term abomination
to an entirely new level
one look at this bill and you wonder
whether congresswoman jackson lee ever
heard of the bill of rights
which includes the second amendment the
bill would also ban all
50 caliber weapons all 50 counts not
just bmg
all 50 cal now my friends a couple years
ago i talked about i was like oh why
maybe you have liability insurance or
you know a license and someone responded
to me
that's great it's a really good idea tim
i'm totally in favor of getting you
insurance liability insurance for your
speech and you have to get a license to
be able to speak publicly
and then i was like wait wait no no i
don't want that like oh
i see your point the bill of rights says
these things are
in uh you know inalienable rights we
have the right to keep and bear arms we
have the right to speak and i said
okay that's that you're right i don't
want any restrictions on my speech
for the you know for the most part
except for like committing a crime and
it's already illegal to commit a crime
with a weapon
therefore all right you should keep all
the k should be able to have a weapon
now they're doing everything in their
power to you know make these moves
we knew it was coming under joe biden
but this when i read this
like it's a whole intention steroid is
an understatement yeah
more importantly i don't think it will
pass because you're going to have
some you know more moderate democrats
especially like
i can't see bernie sanders agreeing with
this well there are so some pro-gun
democrats out there but we also have to
remember there has been a huge
surge of new gun owners a lot of them
from
cities a lot of them from democratic
areas that are understanding that hey
you know maybe i shouldn't wait 15 20 30
minutes for a police to respond maybe
it'll be better if i have something that
i could defend myself with just like all
the celebrities and politicians have
you know they have all these security
guards they have all these people always
protecting them with firearms
and and with this you know law with this
resolution that they're trying to get
past hr 127
this is going to lead to massive amount
of harm
this is going to lead to a massive
amount of problems
that's only going to make the situation
that much would ban gun ownership for
people under 21.
what it's not going to happen that's
that is like you're you're a legal adult
at 18 you have constitutional rights you
can fight in the military at 18. yeah i
mean we've all we've already seen just
how bad
the laws are and you know what you know
i was really i've been thinking a lot
more about this
as i now own a decent quantity of
firearms myself uh my opinion on 2a has
gone
super far into pro 2a whatever you want
to call it
the the the second amendment says the
right to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
the right to bear arms shall not be
infringed right
yeah so should i be able to walk around
bearing arms
well depends on where you're walking
around but for the most part where why
what does that mean when you're walking
around my living room i might have a say
in it well that's private property yeah
there's nothing to do with the gun
if look if someone breaks your house
with a gun it's a crime even if i
invited you over and you just
pulled out a gun and i didn't know you
had one yes i'm gonna leave probably
freak out yeah but is that it's not a
crime
if you invite someone your house the
issue is in many places
in like the vast majority of places the
government tells you can't bear arms
no lie like legitimately i was at the
post office the other day
and there was a sign in the door saying
it is a violation of federal law to have
a firearm inside you know post
post office or whatever and i was like
how do they do that
does the constitution not exist i'm
sorry i'm not saying it's a good thing
to walk around with a gun literally
everywhere like
i'm not saying that someone should open
carry walking into a post office i'm
saying
isn't it weird the constitution says you
can't do it and they literally did
and that's it the constitution is beyond
swiss cheese it is tattered rags
so while i look at this and i'm thinking
it won't pass when you look at what you
know luke and
other people are calling security
theater you look at the rage people have
and the manipulation tactics are
starting to fail they are getting scared
to the point where i think they'll try
and ram this through
yeah maybe but it's junk i mean you
can't there's so many
ghost guns now that have been 3d printed
and unregistered no one's gonna
those people reality check are not going
to register their weapons and if you try
and pass a stupid bill like that
you're going to make a large segment of
the american people criminals
and then that will lead to civil unrest
at a level we haven't seen yet so don't
do it
well normally i'd say i wouldn't
necessarily agree because i think
the american people typically comply but
i read a story about red flag laws
there was this old guy and was
apparently like i don't know some like
ex-girlfriend or ex-wife
called the police saying he was unwell
and he was armed so the police came to
serve a red flag
warrant or whatever they call it that's
where they take your guns away they show
up at your house you've committed no
crime and they say
someone thinks you're unwell you have to
give us your guns and then wait a period
until you go undergo an evaluation and
then you get your guns back and if you
fail then you'll get your guns back
so this guy he's an older guy he's in
his 60s i guess here's a knock at the
door
and he grabs his gun and he answers the
door with the gun and the cops tell him
we're here to take your guns and he says
like hell you are and so they fight over
his gun and then they shot and killed
the guy
when people say my cold dead hands they
mean it right and and
god forbid a situation where the cops go
to serve something like that and the
cops get killed
and then the cops are like i'm not
serving those stupid red flag things
anymore i'm not putting myself there i'm
not going into someone's
house when they're armed and crazy to
take their weapon that's not my job
let me ask you luke are you familiar
with the phrase
when the government when the people fear
their government there's tyranny but
when the government fears their people
there's liberty
i think i heard about that one thomas
jefferson was it
i believe so i don't know um you know i
i believe that was it
what what these barricades that are
being put up around dc are they for a
foreign threat
definitely not the government seems to
fear its people right now but i'm not
seeing a whole lot of liberty
yeah and also you know a lot of the
things that are
called upon with this house resolution
are absolutely nonsensical they don't
make any sense if you want to stop
gun violence you would deal with inner
cities
where guns are banned that's where most
of the gun homicides are at
same with suicide same with police
officer shootings when you look at the
statistics
people having the ability to defend
themselves is not a bad
thing overall especially in the kind of
grander experiment in the united states
if you look at places that are more gun
friendly where you have more freedoms
to bear arms you have a lot less crime
you have a lot less
murders you have a lot less homicides
and i think that's because people
are are equalized by knowing that they
could defend themselves are you allowed
to open carry
in austin texas i don't know about
austin texas specifically they do have a
very left-leaning
mayor and a lot of transplants from
california do move there
gun laws are extremely spotty all over
the united states
there's no universal law you know places
in new hampshire you could literally
open carry anywhere and everywhere you
go except for federal buildings
uh but other places like new york city
they make you jump
through impossible hoops just to get a
firearm for
personal home defense so again they vary
it all depends on the state and there's
so many different laws that ban one
thing in one state but it's totally
legal in another state
well i looked up austin texas.gov and it
says that
you can open carry in the state of texas
is there widespread death mayhem and
murder from people who are legally
owning guns
in the city in texas not that we've
seen you know so i was i was looking at
some rural areas
and you know driving around places in
west virginia and wondering
you know i was thinking to myself it's
really funny there's like volunteer fire
department
there's no real police department it's
like sheriffs so so
where's all the where's all the gun
violence from all these these gun owners
in the inner cities it doesn't make deep
cities but that's not true for austin
like austin has opened texas is legit so
what's
wrong with new york california and
chicago they're packed in
well people people don't no that's not i
mean people are sure if a criminal wants
a gun
or a weapon or to hurt someone they're
going to find it one way or another in
europe they're using trucks they're
using buses they're using knives
and there's even conversations in the
united kingdom about banning knives and
they have in some jurisdictions
they arrested there was this big story a
couple years ago where they arrested a
construction worker for having i think a
leatherman
and they're like it's a knife sir and he
was like but the law exempts like tools
and they're like sir it's a knife
and so they confiscated and gave him
give him a fine or something like that
that's that's uh that's the uk dude i
i've seen i've seen stories about kids
in my neighborhood tying a shoelace to a
padlock and then swinging it and
whacking someone in the head with it so
they banned padlocks no joke
they were like padlocks are banned and i
was like why and they're like
because someone tied it to a shoelace
and wax you could fill a sock with sand
and
break someone's skull with it you don't
ban sand yeah
well sand sand man the beast sand
wouldn't work all that well you have to
do quarters
that's what they do they put they put
chains quarters would do it and then
they put in a sock and
forks make people fat we should ban
forks you could stab someone with a fork
you may want to be careful
you may want to consider it i'm not even
going to joke about that no it really is
crazy to me that there's there's
there's serious cultural problems and
guns there's no correlation
i mean look people in new york have guns
and people will get shot
it's getting worse and worse and worse
it's up the ridiculous amount
percentage-wise
chicago right but why is it that in
places where guns are heavily
heavily restricted you have these
problems and in places where guns aren't
heavily restricted you kind of don't
have these problems
pharmaceutical drugs okay banning these
tools won't make a difference because it
won't address the problems that
you know particular cities are dealing
with cultural problems family
problems father problems family problems
there's a lot of bigger issues out there
that if you really want to prevent harm
you could actually do one of my favorite
things was
you know i saw an advertisement i
actually saw this on reddit too and it
was eat mcdonald's and right next to
it it was like social distance it's for
your safety it's like
you know you have these two larger
contradictory messages out there
you know in in this idea that the
government cares for you that we need a
bigger government to fix
the the government's problems that they
created themselves it's just
it's insane and and gun control i mean
it's a step
towards total tyranny because once they
go after that
i mean anything's on the table for what
they could do to you and we saw
governments in canada governments in
australia really
push it to the limit to what they could
do with their citizens
right after they got rid of their
ability to have uh you know firearms and
we saw
huge legislation canada australia that
that
almost eliminated people's abilities to
defend themselves it's not even
i i don't i think you know you're saying
banning the tool won't change anything
and i i think even out in places like
west virginia
gun laws are it's it's totally cultural
everything we're seeing the crime the
problems culture problems
the the the lack of crime and often has
nothing to do with guns i don't think
the fact that someone can open carry
deters crime
i i'm thinking about how you can talk to
a sheriff and he's going to be like hey
man
you know i'm not going to go in and mess
with you and do these things you go to
new york and tony baloney pepper sprays
forward on the street for no reason
it's cultural problems in big cities
where people are nasty
and you know what i think it is a lot of
people say like oh it's the blue it's
the democrats and i'm like no no i think
i think culture and decay in blue cities
leads to corrupt politicians who use
feel-good democrat policies to gain
power
and then you look at these other cities
where they have open carrying things
like that
it's because they're more trusting of
each other it's like you want to open
carry sure i'm not worried about
you i don't think you're going to shoot
me right in new york they're like you
can't have that because i'm worried
you're going to shoot me
in dc they put up big fences and a
security primer because they're scared
people are going to come after them
it's it's absolutely hypocritical to see
individuals like nancy pelosi that
that wants machine guns at the capitol
telling you you can't have a firearm you
can't defend yourself you can't have a
weapon of war and we're seeing such
bastardized language
we're seeing such orwellian tactics used
here to make you paint
as as some kind of crazy terrorist
criminal if you believe in the right to
defend yourself no no you're just a
logical
thinking human being that understands
just like as you keep saying to him it's
important to have a fire extinguisher in
your house
because again it's not that you're going
to of course look for fires
but but it's there in case there is one
and that preventative
prevents a lot of crime let's just be
honest here when we see
strong armed robberies they don't take
place where they have a lot of
individuals that are
that are armed they usually take place
in situations where people are disarmed
so so what's what's that movie with uh
gerard butler
and the guys break into his house and
like kill his family and then becomes
like this crazy revenge rampage
yeah i don't know the name of it what
was that what was that movie i forgot i
don't
he's great i'm not a big movie guy so
it's it's gerard butler
and what is this leonidas from 300. let
me see if i can look this up
did you watch it what happened in the
movie i haven't seen the movie i just
like
it's a law-abiding citizen ah so he's a
work he's like he's a dad he's got a
wife and a kid and then one day there's
his doorbell rings and he opens it and
then he immediately gets smacked in
there with a baseball bat and falls down
they zip tie his hands and then they
murder his wife and his daughter
later on when these guys get probation
or whatever or you know get off on good
behavior
he kidnaps and tortures them and then
publicly releases the evidence
purposefully want to go to prison and
then tries to get revenge on the system
i digress i'm not making a point about
that i thought it's a great movie i wish
i think that the ending was bad but you
know that is what it is but i was
thinking about that
and i'm like based on this character's
willingness
to like get revenge you know he doesn't
seem like gerard's baller's character
does not seem like a
shy man to say the least but i was
thinking about
even having a firearm in your home is no
guarantee you'll be prepared for when
the threat really really comes
yeah which is why being able to open
carry is important being able to have
your weapon on you
and being comfortable confident and well
trained
because when you answer the door someone
might crack in with a baseball bat
i mean it's it's a movie i know but you
know i think about this
just working here and everything like
that and and wondering about what's the
point of even having a fire extinguisher
if it's too far away and a fire happens
you can't put it out
right when chaos ensues things happen
fast you
to have so so we put fire extinguishers
in like every room
like most businesses will do this all
the fire extinguishers in every room
okay well what happens if you see these
you know i love you see this commercial
there's a gun control commercial
where a guy angrily storms into an
office with a musket and then he fires
once and then he stops and he starts
loading it he pours the powder in and he
puts the ball and he starts stuffing it
and it's like uh-huh we get the point
and they were like this is what the
founding fathers expected
and i'm like how do you subdue a threat
when
kids can go into a school with any
weapon they want and go on a rampage
like how do you stop the threat you got
to go to the root that's my thing i
don't know if you can
you can you can try and make less
threats that's probably the best way to
do it and i think the threats are
pharmaceutical drugs personally
i think that a lot of inner city crime
comes from drugs or alcohol abuse
and desperation poverty that leads to
those kind of things it's easy to get a
40.
it's easy to that doesn't get get it out
so now you're blaming people for smoking
weed and drinking but when you look at a
lot of mass shootings these kids
are whacked out these humans have like
wide eyes i think they look like they're
on something
i would disagree with you saying if
someone gets high or drunk they go shoot
up places especially if they get i don't
think that's
true but but i think the point that
you're getting at is that a lot of mass
shooting events
were connected to individuals who were
on ssr notably yeah
well so yes but the point i'm saying is
it's there's there's cultural issues
in chicago a leading factor for these
shootings is
lovers trysts like i i went night
crawling and
a bunch of these deaths we were tracking
was a guy smack talking some other guy
on twitter about
or or snapchat about some girl he was
hooking up with people think
it's gangs it's not so there is a
culture issue
we used to have duels we used to
actually have this i guess now
what they're doing is nothing to do with
honor it's just like the willingness to
kill someone who slights you
back in the day that at least give you
10 paces and then you turn right
what's happening in chicago is a guy
will post on snapchat like you know
after your girlfriend the guy says oh
you're going to get it and then the guy
drives his house and shoots the other
guy that's what's happening in chicago
so that's a cultural problem where
someone's willing to kill someone else
we just said this story
where some young girls stabbed another
girl to death just because like
they they were bragging about it on
social media that's another part that's
absolutely awesome
that's why they're young children it has
nothing to do with guns i think guns are
a scapegoat for the deep-seated cultural
problems and the
and the cultural decay affecting this
well humans have been killing each other
forever but what i'm saying is if you go
to austin and everyone's open caring and
you're not having this extremely high
murder rate
then what's going on in new york city
something is broken and has nothing to
do with guns
because there's no correlation between
the murder and guns
if you look at you know the city of
chiron
they are arming themselves illegally
because the mexican government
tells them to stop uh arming themselves
they told them to give up their weapons
and their death rate in their town went
to zero percent it was some of the
highest
debt death rate in all of mexico went to
zero
when the citizens started to arm
themselves and literally kicked out the
government and the police and the
cartels
all along in one smooth move so we're
having an individuals that are armed
that do have a lot of
firearms that are protected that have
their own militias that do open carry
throughout the streets
and you have zero murders when you had
hundreds of murders beforehand and the
highest death rate in all of mexico in
michoacan
one of the deadliest states of all of
mexico
so so that's another tale that i think
is worth noting worth talking about here
with this larger debate especially in
mexico where guns are
illegal but homicides by firearms are
extremely high
maybe you know that thomas jefferson
quote assuming it was jefferson it is
jefferson it is jefferson
you got it right yeah maybe maybe the
issue is actually people should
reasonably respect
trust and fear each other yeah
reasonably yeah what i mean what i mean
by that is
i should you know look if you've got
some dude who's like six six and like
220 just sheer muscle or 250 or whatever
and i don't know what what the right
muscle mass to like height would be but
like some super ripped dude jack murphy
well some super jack murphy dude yeah
but like
super soldier i don't know if jack
murphy's a super soldier
he's just tall just think of jack murphy
while we're telling him no i'm talking
about like a like a he-man type yeah
and he walks around knowing that he's
bigger and stronger than everyone and
pushes him around
now you have a five foot tall woman and
he's laughing at her mocking her
and then she's got on her on her waist
you know she's got
a revolver and so all of a sudden he's a
bit more respectful
it's it's people know like with with
being armed and being respectful
trustworthy but also
having something you know giving someone
reasonable fear of if they screw with
you they have something to fear
this this way you might have back in the
day some big tall guy who knows he's
stronger than you can push you around
now i've got everybody who's armed and
they're going to be like
i'm not worried about you shooting me
but i'm not going to screw with you
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time